que puis-je faire pour vous faire autre
chose Lamborghini vous savez qui je suis
avec toutes mes Ferrari il y a un
problème c'est l'embrayage j'ai une
solution vous pourriez envisager un
partenariat Ferrari et Lamborghini
retournez à votre tracteur fermé
[Musique]
à quoi tu penses à une voiture qui
n'existe pas encore aussi forte
puissante et inoubliable que story la
voiture qui jettera Ferrari aux
oubliettes de l'histoire Lamborghini
sera la nouveauté de la prochaine saison
automobile vous êtes soit un
constructeur automobile soit un rêveur
faire autre chose
je ne pense pas que ce soit bien sage on
risque de tout perdre arrête tout ce qui
compte en fait c'est le grand
Lamborghini qu'est-ce que tu veux que je
fasse
vous savez ce qu'on dit de Lamborghini
qu'il est trop peu éduqué pour
comprendre qu'il ne sait pas la
Lamborghini 350 GT doit être aussi
rapide que de toiture de course ça doit
être la plus belle voiture que le monde
est jamais vu
dans six mois à Genève les gens
chercheront la prochaine Ferrari ce
qu'il
trouveront première Lamborghini vous
achetez une Ferrari pour devenir
quelqu'un vous achetez une Lamborghini
quand vous êtes quelqu'un
qu'est-ce que vous dessinez qu'est-ce
que vous voyez des lignes sur une
serviette et vous qu'est-ce que vous
voyez
[Musique]